[Musique]
accède gar bonjour
vous êtes à partir de la French tech et
vous êtes le fondateur de axe pays c'est
une société qui a pour but de protéger
les inventeurs qui est né en 2016 à peu
près exactement alors racontez-nous
pourquoi pourquoi il faut protéger les
aventures alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut protéger les inventions inventées
c'est bien maintenant
protéger ses inventions avant de avant
de les divulguer c'est beaucoup mieux
pourquoi quand on a une bonne idée
le risque principal c'est quoi c'est
qu'on se la fasse piquer très vite quand
on a une mauvaise idée généralement on
n'a pas de problème de propriété
industrielle vous avez vu beaucoup de
jours de d'aventure qui se sont fait
piquer des idées ouais il y a eu des cas
comme ça ou justement les inventeurs se
disent bon on va pas déposer de brevet
finalement ils vont voir des gros ils
présentent leurs projets et finalement
quand on leur dit ok votre projet
on est d'accord pour vous aussi mais ça
doit être 3 ou 10 fois moins cher à un
moment donné ils sont bloqués et on leur
dit écoutez soit vous faites fabriquer
en Chine soit on se débrouille
différemment et s'ils ont pas de moyens
d'interdire assez gros là de refaire
leur inventions
quelque part
c'est plus compliqué exactement et donc
ça veut dire quoi c'est veut dire qu'il
faut dès qu'on a une invention et qu'on
y croit
il faut la déposer il faut déposer le
brevet exactement le réflexe en fait
avant de communiquer sur un avance sur
une invention c'est vraiment de se dire
c'est la protéger ça coûte cher alors ça
coûte cher ça dépend en fait le brevet
c'est un droit d'interdire d'accord sur
des territoires donnés généralement
pendant une période de 20 ans donc quand
on dit sur des territoires donnés
effectivement si on veut pouvoir
interdire au monde entier de refaire son
invention c'est très cher maintenant si
on se limite uniquement à la France
c'est déjà mieux que rien et c'est
de protection c'est une protection et
c'est une protection qui est pas
extrêmement cher par rapport à l'abandon
complètement d'une start-up au bout de
deux ans parce que finalement ça fait
manger par quelqu'un de plus gros et
quel est l'intérêt de faire appel à ce
pays plutôt que de d'aller voir c'est
pas les organismes de brevet de faire ce
protection soi-même alors nous en tant
que conseil en propriété industrielle on
a forcément du coup un bac + 5 dans un
domaine scientifique après on a fait des
études en droit et l'idée c'est qu'on
soit capable en fait de comprendre
l'invention de la traduire ensuite en
langage juridique on a souvent des
inventeurs qui vont rédiger eux-mêmes
leur demande de brevet mais bon et c'est
pas bon malheureusement c'est pas bon il
y a des fois c'est c'est pas mauvais
mais en fait c'est quand que les choses
parfois manque l'expertise exactement et
vous avez aussi donc une expertise
scientifique vous pouvez dire non ça ça
existe déjà par exemple c'est pas la
peine d'aller plus loin ou changer un
peu vos axes de recherche et une
expertise juridique évidemment pour les
de brevet pour savoir comment on fait un
dossier comment le exactement nous on
est là pour accompagner on est là pour
accompagner les inventeurs et du coup on
va être capable d'être en mesure de déjà
de comprendre si l'invention est
potentiellement brevetable ou pas donc
si c'est une solution technique un
problème technique d'accord pour avoir
un brevet il y a toujours cette notion
de technicité qui est très importante et
ensuite voilà on l'accompagne dans la
dans le dans la stratégie en fait de la
protection de la protection exactement
et on retrouve expédio on trouve
facilement accpi oui on est donc on est
basé sur le plateau de Saclay et on est
basé aussi en région Nice Côte d'Azur
d'accord avec cette gare merci beaucoup
merci à vous
[Musique]